lovers of street art can pick out zoosk
life-sized works right away zoosk keeps
his real name a secret he's been
spraying portraits of women on to big
city walls since he was a teenager buns
I'm aphelion it was the summer holidays
we were riding our bikes through the
neighborhood when we found a spray can
in a parking lot one of us sprayed a car
tire or something and then just left the
spray can there so we took it and
brought it to our hiding place under an
old railway bridge that acted as our
base and storage depot and that was when
we started playing with spray cans and
then we realized that had a real magic
to it oh I'm connected to something me
Maggie 19 years on the polish-born
sprayer is a big-time artist today's
soups has a studio somewhere in Berlin
and his art is everywhere it's on the
walls of big European cities like Rome
Vienna and London inns mention it's a
beautiful woman in a beautiful dress on
an old wall on an old grubby wall that
slowly falling to bits and the woman
falls to bits along with a wall the
woman lives as long as the wall does he
need practitioner talent it
zoosk hopes his street art works make
art more accessible for people who don't
go to galleries that's also team oh shiz
goal suks was one of the artists who
inspired Shaw when he decided to become
a photographer for the last three years
Shaw I've from manheim has traveled to
big German cities and photographed
street art there he now has an archive
of around 200 thousand photos I'm really
interested in that movement it's great
that the work tends to hang around a bit
longer these days because they're often
gone from public spaces pretty quickly
they get worn away or removed but I
think it's worth preserving the pictures
Timo shall says that works by street
artists are what gives city's character
even if many people just ignore them
when they want by this is a work by
separating they apply their works
directly to grills and fence posts you
can only see them from a certain angle I
think it's really cool
two years ago Shah put his pictures
online under the pseudonym poly fix that
collection became one of the internet's
biggest platforms for street art his
facebook page street art in germany has
around nine hundred thousand fans the
success of the website is now prompted a
book with the same name the anthology
features 400 photos including a work by
berlin artist zoosk from zoosk a visa
visa i found a lot of pieces by tux when
I went to Berlin for the first time and
when I went to Hamburg I found this that
really made my day you find work by him
everywhere I think he was one of the
first people in Germany who could really
do good clean stenciling he was one of
the first back to zoosk to do in Berlin
street artists use different techniques
to make their point zoosk trademark is
stencils of glamorous models he bases
his stencils on pictures of women in
glossy magazines his work takes aim at
the hype and consumerism of the fashion
industry his art is about how quickly
beauty can fade think of the [ __ ] does
it feel so feeling I think that people
think too much about superficial things
like appearance like status symbols both
of those are actually here today gone
tomorrow so a flashy cars chic today but
not ten years from now people waste
their energy on things like that and
zuke's images prove that we're just
scratching the surface of street art
you